- [Voiceover] Oh, red velvet!
- It doesn't taste like red velvet at all.
- I like the initial taste,
like I'm like, "Yeah!"
It's like a cold cookie
and then it just kind of takes me like...
- Maybe the super young generation,
maybe your teen could deal
with that kind of sugar
but, you know, I'm an old guy...
- A chocolate covered raisin
or something, like a
chocolate covered berry...
- I don't want to know how
many calories are in here
but I like it otherwise.
- Cotton candy, oh my
God, that's delicious.
It tastes more like raspberry I would say
than cotton candy but
I'm a big fan of that.
- That double bubble bubble gum...
- What is cotton candy? It's just sugar.
- Pink milk that all the
kids drank in the 90s.
- Coffee is very adulty and
cotton candy is very kid-like
and it tastes like
something inappropriate.
- An empty clown smile unfortunately,
so big negative on the cotton candy.
- [Voiceover] We're
still at the state fair.
- We had cotton candy and
now we're having caramel.
- At least we're getting
into the coffee universe.
- I'm kinda not mad at this one.
- Really insane milkshake.
- See that to me is pretty delicious.
It is really sweet but
it's dark, it's chocolatey.
This is the first one that I really like.
- [Voiceover] Cinnamon roll.
- This tastes like the mall.
- Okay, no. Oh my God. Oh no.
- This tastes like
arroz con leche I'd say.
- Ugh.
- Pillsbury on crack right here.
I love lemon bars.
Lemon bars in liquid form,
I'm very skeptical of.
- I liked it. It summery, it's
fun and flirty for summer.
- No, I almost feel like this is something
that would make me sick.
- It's not good. There's
no tartness to it like...
- I've never tasted
something like this before.
It's not even that it's just whoa, sweet.
It's like, how interesting.
- If you had cupcake flavor siracha,
I'd give it a shot.
- Alright, this is, this is like a muted
vanilla bean milkshake.
- It takes like a cupcake
flavored candle smells.
- Also you can't name a
flavor after something
that has multiple flavors.
- What is this? What
cupcake have they decided
is worthy of getting the cupcake flavor?
- Yeah, so cupcake so
far, my favorite one,
because it's the most subtle.
- These taste like melted frozen yogurt.
- They're too sugary.
- The world's falling apart.
Better to just go get one
of these things and enjoy it
because we're either
gonna run out of water
or a tornado's coming or something
so just get a treat, put it in your face.
- Luckily they won't be around for long.
- I'm excited about the
future of frappuccinos.
- I vote for caramel cocoa cluster.
- I vote for lemon bar.
- Cinnamon roll!
- Red velvet.
- For cupcake.
- I think I vote for cotton
candy. This is fantastic.
- Frozen coffee, it's a
treat, it's a dessert,
so you know it has it's own
place in the dessert world,
as to where you have a
nice cup of black coffee.